-We have something in common.
We were discussing backstage.
Both of our mothers --
French teachers.
-Yes.
-Yeah. Did that mean --
Does that mean you're good
at it? Do you know it?
-No. I was for a while.
-Yeah.
-How about you?
-Never.
And she was my French teacher.
Was she your actual --
-Yeah.
Well, I had a French teacher
in school,
and then my mom
taught me at home.
-Oh, that's a passive-aggressive
comment on the one at school.
-I was -- You know what?
I think I was good for a while,
but, then, I haven't
spoken it in 20 years.
I kind of understand
a little bit.
-Yeah. I always feel it's
dangerous when you tell people
your mom's a French teacher
because then they just jump
to the assumption
that you listened to your mother
and now know French.
-Immediately.
And you're like,
"Oh, no, no, no! I'm a bad kid!"
-Yeah.
-You have two sons.
-That's right.
-And they were huge fans of
the first "Quiet Place" film.
-Yeah, so, we went
to see it in the cinema.
I suppose it's two years ago,
the first one came out.
-Yeah.
I think that's about right.
-Yeah, the three of us.
Just the three of us.
And I didn't really know
that much about the movie.
I knew it was good.
But I said,
"Come on, guys, we'll go."
And so we watched it,
and, you know, they had --
I think they had these hoodies,
so by the end of it,
they were just sat with the
hoodies like this, watching it.
And, you know,
it's a magnificent achievement,
the first movie.
And for me, the thing
that I loved so much about it
was the emotion.
-Sure.
-It just hit me emotionally,
you know?
-I wonder, as a dad -- I think
it will hit me emotionally
when I'm with my kids at a film
that is affecting them that way.
Like, being scared,
I remember as a kid,
being such an exciting
thing in the cinema.
It must have been so fun
to be with your kids
and watching how movies
affect them.
-Yes, it was,
and because, essentially,
it's a film about family,
as is the sequel, you know?
And it's a film that insists
On being watched in a cinema
with others
'cause it's
a collective experience.
You feel that anxiety
and that jeopardy
and that tension with
everybody else in the cinema,
which is kind of what
it was made for, cinema.
-Are they then very excited that
their dad is in the sequel?
-Well, how will I put this?
Like, I'm not cool,
but I'm not uncool.
So I'm like --
-You just found that
soft middle of dadhood?
-Yeah, I'm like, "Well, okay."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause, you know,
it doesn't strike --
I'm a huge fan of your films.
There's not a lot
of kid-friendly work.
Like, it must be nice for them
to finally have something
they can see you in.
-No, I was like --
It's only now that some stuff
is not highly inappropriate.
-Yeah, 'cause I've never heard
someone say, "Oh, you have kids?
You've got to watch
'Peaky Blinders.'"
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. No.
-Yeah.
-No.
-That must be a weird show
to be a part of
because this started
as a very small production,
"Peaky Blinders."
-Yes. Yeah.
-This was not one of those
"Game of Thrones" type shows
that was aiming for the stars.
It just sort of built a very
large international following.
-Yeah.
-Has it been a trip to be a part
of something like that?
-Oh, for sure. You know,
it started as a little show
on BBC Two in the UK.
And then very -- 'Cause
it had no advertising budget.
The BBC don't generally
advertise.
So it just --
It was word of mouth, you know?
Just word of mouth.
And gradually --
We've been doing it now --
We've been shooting it for
eight years or something,
and we're about to start
series six,
so, yeah, it's crazy how many
people across the world
and how obsessive the fan --
and loyal the fans are.
-And it's --
-"Loyal."
-Loyal. Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, and I hope --
I hope this comment will not
run afoul of your fan base,
but the show had to be very good
for people to get over
how bad a title
"Peaky Blinders" is.
-[ Laughs ]
-You thought this, as well.
-I mean, I was confused.
-Yeah, it's a very confusing --
"Peaky Blinders" seems like
the name of a cartoon horse.
[ Laughter ]
And if you haven't seen
the show, it's not that.
-No. There's some horses in it.
-Yeah, there are some horses.
And the -- One of the many great
things about "Peaky Blinders"
is the haircuts.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know, you obviously
have to then have that haircut.
Like, that's not --
-Yeah, that's coming in
about ten days' time.
-Yeah. No wonder your kids,
like, have issues.
I'm just saying, they can't
think you're that cool
when you're, like, the one dad
walking around with your sides.
-Well, yeah, that's why they
wear hoodies, and I wear --
-They try to get you
to wear a hoodie.
-Yeah, I -- You know, the
mad thing about that haircut,
as well, it was designed I think
as a sort of a protection
against lice and infestation.
And now all the hipsters
are wearing it.
-Yeah. Does that mean
lice is making a comeback?
[ Laughs ] Might be.
-Who knows?
-That would be the least
of our problems right now.
-That's true.
-You were in the Christopher
Nolan "Dark Knight" films
playing the Scarecrow.
I did not realize --
you auditioned to play Batman.
-Well, yes, amongst
many other actors, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, did you have a sense --
I mean, obviously,
Christopher Nolan
still was a fan of yours
because he put you in the films.
Did you at any point think like,
"Oh, I'm a perfect fit
for this"? Or did you --
When you were
in the Batman suit,
did you think --
What were your thoughts?
'Cause I imagine
that's intimidating.
-No, I never for a moment
thought I was material.
I think I was --
It was obvious
that Christian Bale
was going to be Batman.
At that time, it was clear,
and he's such a magnificent
Batman and Bruce Wayne.
But I did get to -- I think
it was the Val Kilmer suit.
I got to try it on, which
they had to adjust slightly.
But it's a weird thing.
You put it on,
you put the cowl on,
and your voi--
Just, the voice drops.
-Yeah, sure.
-It drops a couple of octaves.
You can't do the Batman voice
without doing the...
[Deep voice] Batman.
-Yeah, yeah.
That's why I couldn't do it
because I would be like,
"I'm Batman!"
They'd be like,
"No, you're not!
Get out of here!
Your just a guy in a suit!"
Hey. Congrats on the film.
Congrats on "Peaky Blinders."
That's so exciting that
we have another season coming.
Thanks so much for being here.
That's Cillian Murphy.